foreign
unemotionally stay keep your heart out
of it because it's it's not developed
put your head in it a little bit I'll
get some pushback sometimes kids will be
like how could I not be mad and I'm like
you're making my point for me people
have a real misunderstanding of basic
Civics who holds power up here what kind
of powers we have as congressmen they
simultaneously want government out of
their lives while you also be a dictator
and do what they want and how do we heal
the rift between left and right because
the reality is you need to work together
in order to have a cohesive country
don't you
that's tough I I do think I think
objectively the left has moved way way
further off the Spectrum than the right
has the right's gotten angrier but I'm
not so sure how our policies have
shifted dramatically you've noted before
how how victimhood and outrage has been
elevated in our society unfortunately on
both sides I think the right did it's
matched the left You Gotta Fight Fire
with Fire right I'm like what fire have
you ever put out with [__] fire
um
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
Fascinating People our terrific guest
today is Navy SEAL best-selling author
and the congressman for the great from
the great state of Texas I've always
wanted to say that Dan Crenshaw welcome
to trigonometry hey thanks for having me
it's a real pleasure thank you for
letting us take over your office I
mentioned that you are a best-selling
author and actually your book fortitude
is one of the things we really wanted to
talk about uh you talk about the fact
that you lost your mum uh when you were
10 years old watched her pass away from
cancer then you you know Skip forward
you become a Navy SEAL you you go out in
deployment you get injured and the
fortitude of dealing with all of that
and that contrasts so sharply with the
culture that we now seem to live in what
is it like for you with your life
experience watching people freak out and
meld down over tiny little things all
the time yeah geez Where Do We Begin so
what are the chapters in that book is
called perspectives from Darkness
and the whole point of that book is a
road it's not like a political book
because I'm in a book about Navy Seals
uh it's not even really a book about my
life I mean there's there's a Confluence
of of themes that sort of you know
create this sort of multi-factorial
explanation of the mental sense of
fortitude but
the whole you got to start somewhere so
where do you start well a little
perspective might help and people I
think are objectively more upset just in
general they're like being angry and
fragile and like deeply fragile
um then you know years past and and
maybe that's like the natural tendency
of civilization and you know to some
extent that's okay like we don't need
you to be hard as Nails it's kind of the
point of civilizing but we have come to
a point where maybe it's it's been
overdone a little bit We complain a
little too much about things that we
shouldn't be complaining about and so
it's healthy just I mean just don't you
don't even have to look back that far
back in time
um maybe it's maybe it's past
Generations maybe it's just a few years
ago maybe it's just comparing yourself
to somebody else's situation and think
you know what maybe it's comparing
yourself to your own situation 10 years
ago and you're like you know what I've
been through something harder than this
let me let me get through this too I
don't need to be triggered by this
um I I you know somebody else dealt with
what I'm dealing with now and and they
performed way better than I than I am
now right that's a like a key lesson in
perspective
um we hear it all the time in buds you
know they'll say like look you guys are
you guys are looking pretty miserable
but you know what there's like 10 000
people who've done this before you they
they did just fine so either like sack
up or just get the hell out
um that should be a fortifying message
now to a lot of young people these days
that's like that's like an attack
like you're you're attacking my sense of
well-being you're talking my self-esteem
I was told that I'm perfect the way I am
that's like the worst thing you can do
to somebody I would tell you you're
perfect the way you are if I don't like
you because then I don't want you to
improve I care about you I want you to
improve and seek self-improvement so you
can only do that if you have some kind
of perspective and the reason I bring my
mom into this conversation is because
like I watched her truly suffer and but
I but and I'm not sure that I was really
aware of how badly she was suffering at
the time because she didn't she hid it
from us I mean
she she all we saw was like my best
friend and this this like humorous lady
um made jokes and and still looked after
us and like so you know I'm sitting on
my own kind of not a death bed that's a
little too dramatic but like a a bed
that I can't really move out of um blind
it's like well
you know what I'm still not that lady in
her late 30s dying from cancer
she she manned up maybe I should too
that's that's the point there and you
mentioned perspective it's something you
talk about in the book when you went to
Afghanistan on deployment and you would
see people and you had the sense that
they see the world differently and from
Francis and I both living in the UK very
comfortable very prosperous I'm from
Russia originally I've seen the way that
people live outside the West is mothers
from Venezuela
um you know how do how do you give that
perspective to young people who grow up
and come for who grow up in stability
who grew up in in places that are better
than Humanity has ever experienced how
do we create perspective when there is
none the first I was just telling them
to try learning about it I don't think
it's that much more complicated than
that and I guess not to mentioned I did
have the advantage of I grew up abroad
too so you know I lived in Cairo Egypt
before like before like it was my first
basic memories as a toddler
um deep deep poverty obviously in Kyrie
region I went to high school in Bogota
Colombia so like I know I know what what
bad can look like nothing Columbia's bad
I actually love that place but as far as
inequalities go as far as problems in a
country go a civil war it's kind of it's
kind of a thing and it's it's a real
issue so you appreciate it more when you
when you when you have when you have
here
um so how do you get people to
understand that just tell them so again
I don't think a lot of This is
complicated say hey look there are you
need to be knowledgeable about how
people before you live what the truth is
about say inequality
um and before you guys walked in here I
actually just recorded a podcast with
the economist and Senator Phil Graham
about the of the myths of inequality so
there's like what you're talking about
is really fresh on my mind because we
just had this conversation people have
really people are just misinformed about
basic truths about how other people are
living about what our history is about
what the history of the world is uh and
and what the truth is about economic
disparities discrimination versus
disparities all of these things are just
left is deeply misinformed people for
their own political opportunism right
because it's people have to be
people have to believe there's a crisis
in front of them if they're going to
demand rapid change right Revolution
never took place when people were like I
don't know I think things are fine I do
we need the revolution I I kind of like
you know that they're not going to get
your Bernie Sanders Revolution if
everyone thinks everything is fine
and frankly obviously we're not getting
the Bernie Sanders Revolution so to an
extent people do understand the truth
here but
part of being a conservative is making
sure we don't get there okay so
um telling people presenting the facts I
don't know that it's more complicated
than that Dan do you think part of the
problem as well is that America is such
a materialistic culture that people go
on social media and then they see the
people living these incredible lives and
they get angry and frustrated when their
lives don't match up to what they see on
the screen yeah yeah I'm not sure I must
have expand on it that was America
specific but
um
it's certainly true you know
it's it's almost again it's a it's sort
of a natural outcome of civilization
because in Civilization really smart
people get the opportunity to create
really amazing things that make
everybody's life better
the thing about making everybody's life
better and easier is that it it is a way
it is a form of dependency like if I'm
paying for your rents and paying for
your school and paying for you are going
to be dependent you know it's a natural
human nature left doesn't quite
understand that fact it is true it is a
fundamental truth
um but what we forget about too is the
some of the technological advances of
our time have created that same kind of
lethargy
um and I don't want to reverse it don't
get me wrong
um it is what it is but the easier it is
for someone to live without it being
actually productive you you're gonna
have more unproductive people and that
will increase inequality it is it is a
there's no escaping that set of truths
how do we deal with that as policy
makers I'm not sure I I our job really
is to is to maintain what works you know
again that's the essence of being a
conservative I want to maintain the
principles that work those economic
foundations cultural foundations and
political foundations
um maintain people's freedom within a
set of Rights and a set of policies that
that solve problems through the
framework of limiting principles that's
conservatism
to the extent that we move away from
that it's a dangerous territory and in
your book you've actually put the words
in italics which is outrageous weakness
and that really stuck with me well why
do you think that then
just because you're letting emotions get
the best of you you know
um
just because it doesn't mean it's
unjustified right like my outrage is
Justified like when I give talks I tell
young students all the time I'm like
look just
I didn't have to deal with politics when
I was your age it wasn't a thing for us
like we divided up into friends groups
based on like who listened to Country
and who listened to like alternative
rock like you guys are dividing
yourselves up based on political beliefs
that's insane you always don't know
anything you're you're 16 17 you don't
know anything you don't have a like a
set of experiences that help frame what
you're seeing on a day-to-day basis so
I'm not saying don't get involved I'm
saying learn unemotionally stay keep
your heart out of it because it's it's
not developed put your head in it a
little bit I'll get some pushback
sometimes kids will be like how could I
not be mad and I'm like you're making my
point for me like because I'm like look
the way you're reacting to me whatever
you want to tell me I'm going to tune
out because it's just it's pure emotion
and maybe you're mad about something and
maybe it is Justified right maybe
there's a true Injustice that you're
truly upset about I'm just saying if you
want to be productive about it if you
want to solve that problem you're not
going to get there without rage people
stop listening to you it's just it is
not a practical solution so you've got
to learn to control it you know like in
the steel teams it's like we're not
fearful just like everyone else is not
like we're not outraged just like
everyone else is we just have an extreme
ability to control our aggression and
control our fear that's all it is it
doesn't mean you're Fearless if you're
Fearless you're a psychopath so we're
trying not to like those guys they don't
actually actually don't mesh well so
it's it's really that it's simple
because it means that you've allowed
yourself to give in to a completely
unproductive path
and it's really interesting you say that
because we now celebrate emotion if
somebody is offended it's celebrated if
they're outraged if they're outraged
it's celebrated if they're angry it's
seen as righteous but the point that you
make is that we can't change anything
just with emotion alone yeah that's very
typical if you're kind of far right and
left like spectrums you know like the
biggest indicator of being an extremely
left or extremely right is is their
tendency towards outrage and um and also
the the the preference frankly for a set
of
ideas maybe that that are unsolvable
right because it like they prefer the
outrage like if they feed off of it so
they don't really want to solve the
problem
that's very clear to me after being in
politics for almost five years now so
if you want to solve problems you gotta
you got to keep the emotions out of it I
mean it's it's just really that simple
and and you know uh you obviously a
republican so the fact that you would
take a couple of swipes at the left
makes sense Francis and I are somewhere
in the center we have a lot of center
right guests on like you
um and one of the things I'm thinking
about increasingly is that yes the left
started all this emotional stuff but you
know we're sitting here not very far
from the capital where we saw what
happens when the right does the same
thing uh are you concerned that both
sides are now at this yeah I talk about
all the time so that's why I take so
much Flax on from some of those
audiences um because I call it out I
mean like when you start acting like
this is the populist right the populism
to me is a left-wing sensation okay
because what is populism it's me telling
you what you want to hear right for
popularity's sake well look it yes it is
popular if I just promise the population
three thousand dollar checks every month
for free of course that's popular does
that make it a solid policy course not
right the left is really good at that
kind of stuff I want to buy your vote
I'm going to pay for your school I'm
going to cancel your student debt I'm
going to pay for this and pay for that
I'm going to tax the rich to do it oh
yeah that's that's popular I mean it's
like buying your votes the right
right-wing populists have given into
that nonsense to some extent
um that concerns me a great deal but
what do you make of their argument done
because what they would say is look the
corrupt that lead to right here in
Washington is ruining the country it's
rhinos like Dan Crenshaw you know the
Republicans in name only they don't want
to change anything they want to sit
there and profit off blah blah blah blah
blah what do you say to people like that
I said give me specifics like I'm like
look you can go through your list of
sort of talking points that we can all
read on Twitter like they've been
recycled a million times what does it
mean like what the hell do you mean by
that you know like give me like let's
get down to the actual brass tax what do
you mean and
it becomes this sort of Whirlwind of
answers once we once we get to that
point
um you know you want to profit you're in
everybody's pocket I'm like what does
that mean
people have a real misunderstanding of
basic Civics
um who holds power up here what kind of
powers we have
uh as Congressman I mean people want you
to solve that they simultaneously want
government out of their lives while you
also be a dictator and do what they want
right I I know this because I read the
comments so like why are you posting but
you should be doing this like what did
you do this you know it's like well this
is just how our government works I mean
you're a constitutionalist right so like
you have to follow the Constitution and
the parameters that sets out
um
I I think people say those things too
because they've been conditioned to to
hear those things and then repeat those
things by
by political campaign after political
campaign on the left and the right it's
just become this popular sentiment and
and yeah I guess you could Define
populism that way too just counter
Elites well but again like what the hell
does that mean you know what is it which
Elites why let's get specific and then
and then address that problem within a
set of principles that that we all
adhere to that I thought we agreed upon
not just resentment for resentment's
sake well I I suppose what people mean
is that there is a big disconnect
between what happens in this city and
the lives of ordinary people out there
the values of the people who are here
are very different their way of looking
at the world is different and for a lot
of people I think the reason that
they're tempted by popular populism is
they feel unheard they feel unseen they
feel like uh politicians don't respond
to their needs and and what they want
yeah I mean I just what I would tell
people then again I want specifics like
like you know and I I know not sure
you're in that category so it's hard for
you to come out the specifics because
you're not the one yelling at me about
it yeah but I have had these
conversations and I always try to say
like what that's fine but what do you
mean like give me give me an example of
a policy and it'll give me a policy and
I'll be like okay well just so you know
like that that policy pulls 60 with the
American people's how are we not
listening to the American people
okay just because you know and they're
like I am the people I'm like well
you're not though okay there's there's
actually a lot of you and you think it
does is this what the internet does
everyone has got their own little Silo
and my in my own little Silo I'm the
king of the world I represent the people
and therefore I represent everybody when
actually you're not three percent of
society I hear it all the time we the
people want you to do this I'm like well
you want me to but if you go and pull
your own neighbors you're gonna get a
lot of different opinions man so I think
that's just that's life and I will say
this too that most of the normal people
just going to work like they're actually
not paying attention to my political
posts or they they actually do just talk
about kitchen table issues so you've got
social media has done this right it's
elevated very
um Fringe issues in our politics
actually most people don't really care
about so you do have to use scientific
polling to really get what people care
about then it starts to make more sense
it's like it starts to be like inflation
like basic economics the Border things
that you should expect people to care
about it's it's it becomes a little less
of the kind of lightning rod issues not
the light or not Rod issues don't matter
on day to day
but there's there's like social media
world like you know Twitter isn't real
life it doesn't necessarily translate to
how people are feeling and you know I I
always do feel better when I actually
and I there's a lot when I'm just taking
questions from at my events like back
home because now now I'm hearing from
the people like now I'm actually hearing
from the people especially when I go to
there's there's two different kinds of
events okay there's one where I
advertise it so who's going to show up
to that political people like people are
really interested in politics
um so you have to do other kinds of
events like I'll do like a town hall but
I'll go to a like a specific company and
like get to talk to all their workers
these are all people who would not take
the time to go to some random political
event I don't blame them
um but now I get now I get to hear what
regular people are asking right and it's
it's very different from what your
political entertainment industry wants
you to think they're asking about so I'm
not sure the disconnect is that big I
will say that's the other thing I tell
people is whether you like it or not if
the Congress represents you a lot better
than you think it's wild up here there's
a lot of different types of people they
do represent very very different ideas
and demographies and parts of the
country
you know and then it's messy because
nobody agrees and you don't like that
nothing gets done and I'm like well what
exactly is it you want to get done what
does that mean
and how do you and tell you what go have
dinner with like six of your neighbors
and and you find a kind of a simple
problem and I want you all to agree on a
solution like really think through it
and you tell me that all six of you
agree yeah and now try to get 435 people
to all agree and so you know it just the
the when you actually start doing it
it's a little more complicated than
people realize Dan how do you because
the lift went nuts and I'm from someone
who was on the left quite a while ago
with the embracing of wokism which to me
is a conspiracy theory but now I've seen
the right go just as nuts about things
like Ukraine and Q Anon how do you deal
with your own side when they are quite
frankly losing the plot on the on the
far right
well the good news is kind of bunk I
guess
um but you know the people who followed
Q Anon
the way they think hasn't changed it's a
little it'll happen again
um
they obviously I am where I am on
Ukraine I'm not it's not super secretive
like how I feel about how we should
support Ukraine
um one of the main problems there is
it's a partisan reaction it's Biden's
War so I'm against it like it's honestly
that symbol yeah uh and also like
there's some it's not really spoken
about but it's like well zielinski it
was zelenski's fault that Trump got
impeached you know so there's there's
that it really is like these simplistic
partisan thing there is an isolation
swing to the right there always has been
um kind of goes like up and down like
this it's extremely strong at the moment
and
because nobody's speaking to them I try
to but you got to listen you gotta like
actually download my podcasts to hear
what I'm saying about it I can promise
you I can convince you
um like because I'm not making these
like
Nancy pelosi-esque arguments of like we
have to fight for democracy what the
hell does that mean that's not why we're
doing it we're doing this out of
complete self-interest and what is that
I'm with you by the way on this issue
but to educate us please right so
there's a few lines of self-interest one
is strategic deterrence right you do not
fundamentally want a world where
everyone is invading everyone we lived
in that world for like thousands of
years and how was that world everyone it
sucked it was not good it was like a lot
like your life expectancy was like 28
you had gray hair so it was it was not a
good world to live in you will not have
the same lifestyle you have if you allow
that world to happen right China's
watching the Russian invasion they're
like when can we invade Taiwan how long
will the Americans actually last for
their friends and this is just payments
by the way this isn't even like lives
we're doing we're not we're not spending
a single American life we're saying I
want to avoid the following scenario
because for those because those who
don't want to support Ukraine You by
definition have to support Russia they'd
be like no no I just don't want to stay
out of it well like no no you're
supporting Russia winning because that's
that's the other scenario like if if you
start kicking his ass right now
I have a choice right now
I do I can stop you and I have the
ability to stop you so you know because
I'm just stronger than you so I can stop
you or I can let it happen by definition
if I let it happen I'm choosing choosing
that and so what does that mean in the
Ukraine sense it means that you want an
intact Russian military that's been
emboldened and Hyper aggressive probably
has way more support amongst the Russian
population because Russians like one
thing they like winning like winning and
they they they love strength and now
you're on four more NATO countries
borders how is that a better how is that
a good thing what the hell is wrong with
you and you're telling me that all I
have to do is write a check to
ukrainians and then they'll like stop
that from happening that's a good deal
so strategic returns is a big deal a
world without chaos is a really big deal
um in in two large countries warring is
is chaos and it turns out if you bother
to look at history at all uh European
Wars tend to spread you know it's just
Europeans
um you guys explain it to me
um and they draw Us in so on the other
hand it's like and then they kind of
diminish Ukraine as this like economic
Backwater which is crazy it's like 50 of
the world's neon a ton of iron ore that
we use in our steel like 13 15 of the
world's food supply like you haven't
felt those effects because it is the
economy is still working and they're
still exporting a bunch of that it's not
nothing neon by the way is used for
semiconductors I guess the Taiwan the
situation like everything is connected
like you can't build a freaking pencil
these days in your country you can't it
just not not without it costing like way
more than it should
um now I've had that conversation with
like really conservative high school
students who've like been kind of
captured by this like an emotional way
like by this this kind of
right-wing Bernie sanders-ism
and I'm like dude like the iPhone you
have you can't be like you can't make it
here you just can't you'll never make it
here unless you want to pay ten thousand
dollars for it I mean even then I'm not
so sure you can make it here so he's
like yes we can I'm like who told you
that like I don't have time I I can't
teach you basic economics and the
history more importantly the history of
trade and economics
um in 30 seconds but I promise you it's
not true
so look
um I think that's a that's a succinctive
explanation as I can as I can give you
real quick on on Ukraine uh absolutely
so but Dan what would you say to those
people who go look
we're in real economic trouble in this
country you go into the city centers of
places like La the homelessness
population is exploding there's a
fentanyl crisis this money could be used
to help Americans in America not in some
far-off country yeah it's disappointing
when that kind of argument comes from
the right which is it does come from the
right all the time because I'm like are
you done well you can join the Democrat
Party if you want because that is a
Democrat argument like where money just
solves everything if we can spend a
billion dollars and solve poverty in
downtown in Houston in general like we
would have spent it by now that's not
what solves the problem you know a more
compelling argument is the Border like
why are we worried about their border if
not our border totally fair we should
but but it's like it's a false choice
you don't know if it's not an either or
situation we should do both you people
who know me no I've been pretty hardcore
I don't really talk about your credit I
talk about fighting the Mexican drug
cartels that's what I talk about so I'm
all you know it's not really a money
problem though our border issues not not
a money problem so can you explain this
to us Dan because we have a very similar
problem in the UK where we have tens of
thousands of people coming to the
country on small boats in our case
illegally they don't get checked they
get put up by the government in a hotel
but why are we in the position where
some of the most powerful countries in
the history of the world are unable to
enforce what every other country in the
world does which is a controlled border
yeah well because the the left has
become
Hostage to their own sense of compassion
I guess
you know um I was people asked about
this like why can't Democrats see it our
way and I'm like
there's a couple things there's probably
political incent at least in America
there's probably some political
incentives they think they'll vote for
them eventually I
it's not really good strategy so I'm not
sure that's true but anyway but but I
think fundamentally they they have
different moral reasoning than
conservatives and so so they
they don't even conservatives think that
like loyalty to your group I'm
referencing like Jonathan Heights work
here does it lays this out really well
and explains a lot of policy differences
between the left and the right it does
you know conservatives are pretty even
keeled on all sort of the moral
Frameworks that we might point out like
a sense of authority sanctity a sense of
in-group loyalty which is important when
you're talking about a border uh and
compassion loyalty things like that so
the left really only cares about
compassion and Equity that's their whole
thing so everyone should have the same
thing which means everyone should have
access to all of America's benefits and
I just feel for someone like they're
always a victim right so this is a
victimhood this is kind of where
victimhood culture probably comes from
because
you know
it's you've noted before how how
victimhood and outrage has been elevated
in our society unfortunately on both
sides I think the right did it's going
to match the left because you got to
fight fire with fire right I'm like what
fire have you ever put out with [__]
fire
that's the point I always make it's like
when the fire brigade turn up at your
house they're not turning up with light
as in fuel that's not what they do right
no like could you imagine just just burn
it all down just do it faster
are you worried that's the political
attitude in America at the moment yeah
in both sides drain the swamp or
whatever else yeah abolish abolish
capitalism that seems to be the solution
for both sides yeah that's what populism
is right it's based in emotions based in
Outrage and it's like blame someone else
and and
burn it all down right that's real
dangerous and the left does it
because they're utopianists
um so like when you can't when you
envision Utopia and you're not quite
there what do you do you get mad and you
like want to burn it all down the
problem is is like they're literally
you know I always I tell people look
Envision a librarian and she's like
standing on a bunch of books and she's
almost at the top shelf that's Utopia
but she just can't really reach it and
this really frustrates her and so her
reaction instead of instead of adding
more books to her foundations and those
foundations might be like you know
Christianity or you know a sense of
meritocracy like I'm talking about
really basic foundations capitalism just
burns them all down right and boom they
need the French Revolution that went
really well so
um and on the right like it's I'm gonna
think the writer utopianist but it's
just mad like people just mad like you
know and our job as Leaders is like I
understand why you're mad so here's the
truth about
first let me just like let me give you
the truth about what you think is true
whether it's Washington or this policy
whatever it is first let me do that and
then let me walk you realistically like
how we get to the solution I think you'd
be happy with that's what a Leader's job
is what a lot of leaders do instead is
be like what is it you think again huh I
agree with you totally like that's
populism because I'm like I'm just
mirroring your emotions so that I can
manipulate you that that's what populism
is but let's come back to the
immigration because uh if it was as
simple as the right taking power uh I'd
be you know I'm not on the ride but I'm
but I would support the right if that's
what I thought in the UK we've had a
conservative government well
conservative government since 2010 and
in this country only until very recently
you had a Republican president who did
not solve this problem so why is it that
our country because I feel like it's
almost like it's not just about the
individual circumstances it's almost a
cultural phenomenon where even the right
has actually swallowed a lot of these
leftist ideas of Utopia uh all things to
all men Etc do you think there's some
truth to that
uh no it's just the politics of a gap
Messi probably so
um I will say Trump's policies did
make it a lot better right and it's a
simple disincentive to come across the
border illegally by saying look you can
come across fine but we're gonna we're
gonna you can you can claim Asylum but
you're just gonna wait in Mexico while
we adjudicate that and so obvious so
what that did fundamentally was stop the
abuse of the Asylum system that's the
fundamental problem in our country you
guys have a different problem I think so
it's hard to compare the two you guys
have an act you guys are actively
bringing them in maybe we're allowing
them to come in yeah so
I guess we are too but Trump wasn't
necessarily he was looking for ways he'd
eventually found ways took him a long
time to kind of get to that point
um we didn't have 60 votes in the Senate
honestly the answer is as simple as that
you know you gotta have serious
majorities here to to make that policy
change
um we're going to pass something out of
the house here soon that's that's going
to be a really solid border security and
it's not going to go anywhere um because
I don't maybe we'll get one you need 60
votes in the Senate so that's the simple
explanation I don't I don't think that
there's a single Republican out there
who would be like yeah I mean we should
just keep letting them across like it's
it's pretty well ingrained in our base
to to believe the opposite I know the
reason I bring up the cultural point
though is I talk about this in my book
you know the Barack Obama's the the I
mean Hillary Clinton's the Bill
Clinton's they all sounded to the right
of Donald Trump on immigration in the
Run recently too and recently too so
something has changed in the mindset of
the country on these issues yeah that
that's a that's true that's fascinating
and I've never figured it out I mean
I think
I think they they're might be as simple
as them pandering politically to their
Latin base that's backfired and they are
now they have no way out you have to
understand too that the the
people say all the time the the
politicians of Washington don't want to
solve the immigration problem because
they benefit from it being like a
lightning rod issue all the time I
actually don't think that's true even
for Democrats because we all have plenty
of lightning rod issues and political
footballs that we can throw around
and I'd be really happy to just solve
this one
um
it's the outside groups it's the it's
the groups that like literally make
money off of this people like oh again
it's like going back to like you just
line your pockets what the [__] does
that mean like no we don't like we
literally don't
um but you know who does make a lot of
money
um activists that run these
organizations who take donations from
you and tell you that you're fighting
for them and all that so on the left
those are very very powerful
pro-immigrant groups and I think they're
really scared of them I I think that's a
fundamental Truth uh we have them on the
right too like no they will try to
prevent us from like coming up with a
compromise that would because a
compromise would you know be something
like okay let's figure out what to do
with like a better legal immigration but
like really get the Border secured
um I I would I could foresee a lot of
those far right anti-immigrant groups
torpedoing that I could see that
happening because they don't really want
a solution so I don't think it's the
politicians up here do you think part of
the problem is as well Dan is that
people don't know how Congress Works
they don't know anything about you
how policy is passed so that creates
conspiracy theories yeah
is that some of you find yourself
battling all the time then yeah yeah for
sure it's just all the time like I said
before people think you're a dictator
um pretty pretty consistently why don't
you do something about it Dan I'm like
we'll get just let's lay it out like
what what is the action like like I mean
you know it's it's um yeah it would make
everybody a little less unhappy if I
think they understood the system a
little bit better sounds like a very
frustrating job yeah yeah it's politics
so it's extremely frustrating you do it
because it's important
because it's enjoyable my last job was
pretty enjoyable even if I lose an eye
every once in a while like
very enjoyable
um
no politics you do it because it's
important because you need leaders who
are actually willing to tell people the
truth
um the truth makes people really mad is
is there's a lot of emotional attachment
to false narratives that are comfortable
whether that's how the government works
whether that's the the nature of
inequality and what's true about it
whether that's climate alarmism I don't
know like there's there's plenty of
comfortable false narratives that people
like really enjoy holding on to it makes
them really mad especially if you tell
your own side like Ah that's not right
well you just it's not I hate that yeah
because then you're like a traitor like
no no just say the thing we saw on
Twitter it's like no I can't say the
thing because it's not true so
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
what do you do when you're in a system
that actively rewards that kind of
behavior
how do you navigate that and how do you
maintain a sense of
integrity
yeah well I guess you just gotta hope
that integrity and Truth like wins out
in the end I think it tends to I I'm not
it's not obvious to me that in the long
run it doesn't
um but you're gonna have your battles in
between that that's for sure you don't
have any other choice so that's
never said it was easy things that are
easier usually not very worthwhile
and Trump is
he's got on the comeback Trail do you
think he's what America needs at this
point dad
well he's on the comeback Trail for sure
I'm not going to get into the politics
of the the primary staying out of that
one
um but uh you know we definitely don't
need Biden and Republicans need to well
Republicans need to figure out how to
win
and beating Democrats is really easy I I
find it to be the easiest thing in the
world
I like a barely Republican District I
got redistricted now I'm super
Republican but
um barely Republican before Trump barely
won like like a point he won want to buy
but I want like 14 points so it's not
hard to beat Democrats even when they're
spending a ton of money on me even when
Beto's coming in to campaign against me
and like all this nonsense it's not hard
to beat them really isn't you just got
to be somewhat like like how do you win
an election get enough people to know
who you are and be somewhat likable more
likeable than the other guy that's
winning so this is not a hard thing to
do I mean Democrats are trying to ruin
women's sports they're trying to trying
to tax their business out of existence
they've literally Biden is is making a
deal you said you were going to ask me
what I think people should know about
well here's one thing they should know
that Biden has made a deal with the oecd
maybe like 180 countries signatories
that that if if he isn't able to raise
corporate taxes here in America then
everybody else should raise taxes on our
American companies in their country
what the hell man like I don't care what
side of the aisle you're on that's like
that's like treason it's it's nuts
um is this the global corporate minimum
tax right so
holy crap this shouldn't be that hard to
beat these these folks like most people
do not want an open border like a vast
vast majority most people think you
shouldn't have an abortion past 12 weeks
how are we losing this debate it's not
even most people it's like 60 70 percent
of people don't think you should have
abortion past 12 weeks like
by by pushing the extreme yeah that's
how you lose at the bank yeah and doing
it in an angry way yeah like like you
got to be like look I'm a conservative
I'm just not angry about it that's like
a funny line a lot of people say because
it's so true and it's like look just
just firing rooms I know it right like
and they do it because it Rouse up their
base and they're only interested in
talking to their base I'm like look I'm
interested in actually fighting for my
base and for me to fight for my base I
need and you need to give me the space
to actually do it like you need to give
me the space to persuade other people to
slowly to come over which means I can't
go be an [__] like you want me to be
you know and uh look I think most most
people get that
um I guess the only point I'm making
here is it's easy to be Democrats we
just got to want to do it and how do we
hear the rift between left and right
because the reality is you need to work
together in order to have a cohesive
country don't you
that's tough I I do think I think
objectively the left has moved way way
further off the Spectrum than the right
has the right's gotten angrier but I'm
not so sure how her policies have
shifted dramatically I mean you can
point to some things right like
some things that are good like a
skepticism of trade with China I think
that's a good skepticism to have like
there's nothing in conservative
philosophy that says we just have to let
Chinese do whatever they want free trade
for all like that's actually not a
conservative philosophy domestically
speaking economically yeah it is but the
international trade like you've got to
negotiate so there's some healthy
aspects to the so-called I wouldn't even
call that populist it's just smart
policy
um anyway people point to things like
that but I'm like we haven't really
moved off the deep end that's the whole
point of conservatism it kind of stays
in a box and like people I'm trying to
keep it there the left has been way far
um
you know how how do you solve that man I
don't it does come from the top right
there's there's probably room for some
more things to happen I will say too
like
it's not that hard for me to work with
Democrats I I was just working some
Democrats on a bill just now on on
improving our our health care System
right on working on Direct Primary Care
this is like a very fundamental
conservative philosophy but like some
Democrats are into it so it's not
totally crazy we work together on our
national security committees too like
I'm on the intelligence committee that's
a very bipartisan committee not seeing
this argue in there
um it's helpful when there's no cameras
uh and um armed services committees
usually pretty bipartisan as well so
there's most bills that pass by the far
by far the majority are bipartisan
passes a lot of support now they're not
like changing the world you know we're
always going to disagree on fundamental
things and that's by the way that's the
whole point of having a left and right
um I do think America's just seemed to
me like the last place where it's like
truly 50 50. it doesn't seem that way
anywhere else like I mean maybe argue
with me on that but
you know we need it it's healthy there's
there's something about that that's
healthy I think it'll be like that for
the next Thousand Years
and it was like this a thousand years
ago I think that's naturally wired
within the human race to see things and
sort of the Thomas Soul conflict of
Visions framework right
um
it'll always be that way it's like that
everywhere you guys have different names
for it we call them Republicans
Democrats y'all call it labor and
conservative
you know you need a few more
conservatives I think you know we
absolutely agree on that yeah just a
balance it balance is good balance is
very good what does conservatism mean to
you then because people you you ask
conservatives what it means to them and
you get a million different answers yeah
that's a problem
um most people don't know I said it
earlier so it's a conservation of
Western values fundamentally and I would
I would I would categorize that three
ways cultural political and economic so
cultural just means like
judeo-christian values right I'm gonna
say You're Happy from finding you can be
an atheist but you still adhere to the
same values that judeo-christian uh
morality teaches just you know whether
you like it or not you do and you agree
with it so that's one meritocracy right
like this is these are cultural issues a
personal responsibility like a sense of
personal responsibility a sense of
fortitude like I should be strong like
that's a that's like a real important
cultural thing and like we actually do
have to say it because like you said
earlier people are celebrating weakness
victimhood like that's a that'll destroy
a civilization from within so you know
conservatism has to actually fight for
these basic values I could go on and on
I guess on cultural issues but economic
issues what is that it's just a market
like a free market Society property
rights protected your Basics right like
a a sensible tax system
um that incentivizes proper behavior
disincentivizes negative behavior I
don't think it just this isn't
complicated stuff but
we do find ourselves in disagreement
with the left on it so like
um and political so small or republican
that's what we're preserving as
conservatives you know we're preserving
federalism states rights we're
preserving the idea that if you have a
problem it's likely that the local
people will kind of know how to solve
the problem better than somebody in
Washington so
um you know preserving checks and
balances of preserving the the nature of
the court system and and it's it's
insulation from Congress right like it's
really basic stuff that is actually in
in in sharp disagreement with how the
left wants to operate like what do they
say they want to pack the courts they
want to remove the filibuster like they
want to remove these really basic
political institutions so when I like
describe all that you're like well isn't
that just normal stuff but I'm like yeah
that that's the point like it's just
normal stuff
um and then you know and then we look at
new problems conservatism means having a
framework with which to solve the
problem too many conservatives thinks it
thinks it means don't ever solve a
problem that's a that's a problem like
that's not what it means it means I
approach a problem with a certain
framework in mind and generally that
framework is limiting principles so I
ask questions like okay if I want to
give you a benefit like what do I have
to take from him
that's an important question if I want
to give you free health care but he's a
doctor so like do I like to say you you
just do I pay him do I decide how much
he gets paid how does that work this is
a real these are real questions that
like Liberals are just like no did you
just have it you know like but how do
you have it you know you didn't work for
it how does that work maybe we'll try
and get to that point I'm not saying we
don't but but you got to think about his
rights as well if I want to take your
guns away
okay just to make him feel safe
but like but now you can't protect
yourself but he feels safer well how
about what you know it's like I'm sorry
what like principle are you going back
to feelings or this is the principle of
feelings so yeah it's only conservatives
answer asked these and I could keep
going right like ask these questions
this is best solved at the local level
is it best solved by just Civil Society
we ask those questions and that's like a
test for how we solve a problem you know
and conservatives can internally
disagree on like well it does infringe
on somebody's rights well no it doesn't
let's have that discussion but at least
we're asking the questions
Dan in your book Moving on a little bit
you talk about the values that were
instilled in you as a Navy SEAL uh on a
stepping up when you know when there's
no one in charge you take charge all of
that sort of stuff and they're really
beautiful values for people to get and
to Aspire to
what's the contrast like going from that
to politics where at least from the
outside it seems that the principles are
upside down you know if you can screw
somebody you do if you can throw someone
on the bus you will if you can avoid
being at the front and taking the bullet
you Etc
what's the contrast like I don't know
you put that really well it's exactly
like that
because I I have been people ask me what
has surprised you and I'm like well I'm
not if somebody comes up here and
they're super surprised about everything
you shouldn't have elected them it means
they don't know what the hell they're
doing there's a lot of people like I
can't believe it's like this
why did you run
um like jeez uh so you thought it would
be a bit of a [__] sandwich when you got
there I just understood basic Civics
like I'm like yeah I mean no you don't
get to rule the world when you become a
congressman a lot of people are like
legitimately frustrated by by you know
how slow the system can be and I'm like
what that you really don't understand
what it's for
um what your powers are like what what
what people are very uneducated on basic
policy so that's that's a problem and
the SEAL Teams like you do have to meet
certain standards before you deploy
that ain't the case in a democracy an
electoral politics so that's all I'm
saying um but the the thing that
actually truly surprised me was was the
extent people were willing to throw
someone under the bus and like betray a
friend or me like multiple cases like
this
for almost nothing in return I mean just
for a little just for a quick Glimpse uh
just for a quick like highlight on
Twitter like just for almost not I'm
like wow you stab me in the back for
another at least do it for something man
if I have multiple stories like this or
I could I could name people but I'm like
jeez like it's just like it's almost
psychotic like it's so irrational to me
and like man if you
you would have been better off just
saying nothing he's like now you just
made an enemy
um and so it's it's very irrational
maybe that's poor judgment maybe it's
just like the the snake pit of
um nature of of this game that
everybody's playing and everybody's so
used to there's no loyalties whatsoever
it's like again in the steel teams I'm
like
uh I have a platoon member who's you
know who's an enemy I don't know this
enemy is always trying to hurt this guy
I'm not gonna go have drinks with his
enemy like I'm just not gonna do it but
in politics he's like oh no I mean we
didn't talk about you
what the hell
it's like okay well no dude we're not
friends like it's it's just that yeah
the idea of friendship is almost
non-existent it seems like
um a sense of loyalty yeah the sense of
honor it don't get me wrong it certainly
exists with a lot of people
um most of the people who you probably
never heard about never get credit for
it but there's a lot of them and like it
does need to be noted that there is
um but you do have to you do become
cynical sometimes because you begin to
wonder is that what the people even want
you know or do you want the snake oil
salesman because sometimes it seems like
you do
you know and so this is this is why I
like I find it incumbent on myself to
tell truth about the left and the right
and um and like who's just selling you a
bag of goods and and who isn't like am I
am I telling you what sounds good
because you've been conditioned to hear
it or am I telling you the truth
you know it's um people gotta people
gotta sniff that out well I kind of when
I was reading your book and I was
thinking about the attitude then you
know I heard your conversation with Joe
Rogan as well
um did you ever watch Game of Thrones
yeah I sort of had a sense you might be
a bit of a Ned stock yeah probably
idealistic and then before you know it
you're getting your head chopped off I
had my head chopped off yet
but yeah the Game of Thrones isn't kind
to him but isn't his doesn't his son
went out in the end
right uh isn't that a Sunday yeah yeah
yeah well he's not actually his blood
son but yeah yeah all right tell him
snot we're giving all the spoilers away
here we're ruining it it's a terrible
ending by the way yeah but like I guess
but but but you know but the reality is
is that
in Game of Thrones the the the
quote-unquote truth like the right path
though extremely difficult and with much
sacrifice still one out in the end it
has to so
might be different characters at the end
but it still wins and so yeah you can't
let go of that I mean what do you have
if you if you do let go of that you have
nothing so
it's not worth it it's not worth selling
your soul some people sell their souls
up here because they can't they probably
can't do anything else let's be honest
like I can do plenty of other things uh
so it's just it's not worth selling of
the soul and do you sometimes feel that
that's a problem
that the characters politics attracts
the people who want to be sent to Stage
the people who want to be revered that's
kind of a side effect do you think that
might be the case it depends on the
district really you definitely see that
in some places you see you see that
character get demolished in some
districts right and like a much more
like normal person gets elected say
really
really depends that's why I tell people
all the time I'm like look man the
Congress represents it just fine trust
me you can find your person up here it
might not be your representative but it
is your person like you've got somebody
voting for you like there's a lot of
different characters up here
um it's you know the average IQ up here
is 100.
is just what a great note to wrap up
I've done a couple more questions and
we'll ask you some questions for our
locals well no in fact not a couple our
final question is always the same we did
warn you about it
um why is the SAS better than the Navy
Seals
okay I'm leaving I don't want to get
choked out by a certain Congressman uh
we like them very much honestly what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that you think we should be
oh well I already gave you one answer
you know we probably gotta talk more
about this AI thing remember when I
spoke to you earlier when I said earlier
about the how inequality is inevitable
even with all the policy you know
meddling that you want just because well
first of all people naturally produce
differently naturally different skill
sets naturally or taller shorter uglier
more beautiful whatever there's all that
but also the the fact that that and this
is really only it feels like a very
recent phenomenon last 50 years where
massive innovation has allowed a lot of
people to remain completely unproductive
and live like kings of the future
without knowing anything like anything
and what is AI going to do that can make
it even easier so now you don't have to
know how to write essays like you just
hey hey I write an essay on this I don't
know you don't have to know how to it
seems like
how is a legal profession going to move
forward if if if a legal contract that
used to cost Millions to write you got
to hire a firm to do a corporate merger
cannot be written by AI
is that a good thing or bad thing like I
we just have to talk about it I don't
I'm not sure
um you know you've got really Elon Elon
Musk just announced new AI company
I'm glad and again like I can't probably
you could say look we just have to make
certain Services it have to be done by a
human you could do that well now we just
now we completely stop our own AI
development and let China run around and
run around us run circles around us so
that's not an option either it we got to
think about this
um I haven't really thought a lot about
it but I haven't not come to any
conclusions but
um it's it's these last few months have
really really really fast and Joe Rogan
like release an episode that wasn't him
yeah there was your name is that like
that was that was how long ago was that
that was it was I think Joe released it
a couple of weeks ago yes yeah so this
is moving very fast it's all pretty
recent like that's it's
I don't know man something to keep an
eye on uh well Congressman thank you
very much for giving us your time it's
been absolutely pleasure to chat with
you we're going to ask you a couple of
questions for our supporters that
they've already submitted but for now
thank you guys for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or show all of them go ahead 7pm UK time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast come on over to
locals we'll see you there
so this is uh Benita C and she says what
can be done in America about Shady media
practices in a way that holds our
journalists more accountable without
impacting the freedom of the press
[Music]